[Music]
I'm just having a lot of trouble being
white lately Hey
hi we didn't just magically appear in
chairs like we've obviously spoken
before this moment's you don't need to
do like the hokey hi hey who are you
really good good to see you out of
nowhere I invite you to my house because
I wanted to show you some cards delusion
is this turning into called Little Lulu
what's about little Little Lulu was a
cartoon character created for The
Saturday Evening Post and then David you
don't need to tell me that Lulu came
from The Saturday Evening Post
I don't expect when I invite someone to
my house for them to behave this way
yeah I bet you don't but this is not
your home roll it Jimmy there's nobody
here named Jimmy Lulu by March by March
fair enough Marja sort of the Madonna
the voices get it Board of Education you
see the Oh cuz like I'm I'm tired of it
so apparently this is how the future
starts out every day in this horrible
horrible this will happen in our future
while she's a troublemaker she's a
doorbell
I knows that's Little Lulu boy this is a
different time
whoa did he kiss it now he just maybe
just listen guy get him back tubby
that's right Thank You tubby yeah the
teacher calls his student tubby the
teachers not so not tubby himself though
he's about to beat this kid she okay
what not I wish she was off all she had
in her desk was an apple and a frog and
Mary's got a pillow it's got a desk pill
I'm liking this kid he's our hero
right his bottom gets hit so much and
what year did the Pilgrims land she's
got this
yeah she's got this
[Music]
1492 then when did Columbus discover
America he never did
he found it I like him I like how Toby's
throwing out real years he's like it's
got to sound like a mix up
she should have figured it out the first
time he messed with her yeah I agree
learn your lesson this kid's got pillows
in his desk and steals apples idiot
that's what you do to me when we're on
the road yeah oh they got the cap did
you miss the times when you could just
publicly shame her children so great if
I sit in the corner dumbass they say
it's good for them now we're gonna learn
about this is where I sort of tuned out
oh wow Lulu I mean that I assume as
having an imagination because so at
Lulu's just chasing tubby on the Santa
Maria
check you out Santa Maria I learned to
think it too once I just that bottom is
upsetting come on
what oh my god no what no how did I not
see this coming
how did I not the second arrival of this
is boat B like this is gonna be a
horrible ah just supposed to been good
to be a young Native American to watch
TV back in the day yeah notice how
there's people yeah there's people that
you discovered she's a idiot
what's happening
not have flags work not even remotely in
this country it is you know Wow I mean
so Americans were always
footprint real early on this culture
yeah you don't we're growing flags and
show of fireworks dumbass we're totally
racist we can't do your a place where
you live yeah my
[Music]
so he likes it yeah he liked her but now
it's bottom hurts yeah
Oh back to the book that made no sense
oh they're just falling into different
times of history in the book yeah okay
welcome to the plot I don't know if
that's fair to call it that this is Paul
Revere if you don't know but Tobey is
coming that's the dream of every equine
there to be beaten in a race wow he's
fast
what's his problem he's got a fire
extractor
don't shoot away their eyes ah that's an
interesting camera see what happened
yeah you can't see the whites of his
eyes right what the hell is going on
okay so he's fat and she pulls out an
ice cream where did she get an ice cream
it doesn't matter it's just what she's
just got a laura cone why did we stop
those right hey
[Music]
narrator live hair raid alarm not sure
I'm getting it no scalps Oh God really
yep OOP Cleveland Indians
[Music]
there's a whole lot of racism going on
I'm just what's wrong I'm just having a
lot of trouble being white lately please
don't help the boy she is not like her
history huh
see this better not be from the teacher
no it's from Tubby's but what what isn't
in Tubby's desk can we get a list of
those oh boy
we know how water works it Smurfs you I
think oh I love a beer we're checking a
lot of boxes here child thank you yeah
nice nice racism the abuse of children
making fun of the heavy kid yeah
fat shaming there's a little bit of
stuff that was against Native Americans
phenomena I didn't pick up on any of
that that was in there yeah well I would
a ride America used to be a better place
I think that's all we're learning
through cartoons I just have to remember
that the reason why I'm being shown
these is cuz they're going to be awful
for a second they're dipped into like I
like cartoons and then I was like all
right right these take a dive that one
was fine anyway thanks for coming over
to my house I live here Jimmy could you
lead him out
oh yeah